I guess it's Jonah here so have you ever
been in this situation for the past week
you're doing really well in your workout
you're hitting your personal best and
you haven't missed a workout session all
of a sudden you lose all motivation and
all you want to do is just sit down
snack on ice cream or chips while
watching TV I go through that every
single month ladies we are not men and
our body does not function like a man we
go through our menstrual cycle every
month so our hormones go up and down up
and down every single week we can't
always expect the Train like a man and
we shouldn't feel bad when we can't push
ourselves as hard on certain days but
that also doesn't mean you should just
sit back and do nothing so let's
understand our menstrual cycle and how
we can adjust our exercise routine and
also food intake to match our body's
internal rhythms in general the
menstrual cycle occurs in two phases the
first phase is also known as the
follicular phase so it starts on the
first day you get your period and ends
on the day you ovulate the second phase
is known as the luteal phase it starts
the day after you ovulate and ends on
the first day of your period so on
average it is a 28-day cycle so let's
get to know the follicular phase what's
going on this is the start of your
menstrual cycle on the first few days
estrogen and progesterone will start
very low and on the fourth to fifth day
that's when your estrogen level was
start to rise estrogen levels will
continue to rise on a steady pace
throughout the follicular phase but your
progesterone will remain relatively low
what this means is that your body's pain
tolerance increases and your muscles
recover quicker as well so what workout
should you be doing if you don't
experience any period cramps this is the
best time to take your workout at a much
high and hit and lift those heavy
weights your body will be performing at
its peak and so you really want to
embrace your workout now because you're
more taller
to pain those hit classes of bootcamp
will not feel as difficut and try to
lift slightly heavier than you're used
to you will be surprised how much you
can lift if you're someone who do
experience period cramps
then take it easy do gentle exercises
such as yoga or go for a brisk walk and
it will have to reduce the cran and also
discomfort what should you be eating
during this phase your body uses carbs
as its main source of field so good news
ladies you can increase your carb intake
especially after your workout session to
avoid your body from burning out I'm
talking about good carbs such as yam
statue vegetables rice oats or sweet
potato let's move on to day 7 to 14 this
is right after menstruating so estrogen
will continue to increase to its peak
forget Iran will still remain relatively
low so what workout should you be doing
it is important to also know that a
sturgeon also helps with muscle recovery
and it helps to build muscles at a
faster pace so you want to take
advantage of this hormonal change and
really lift those heavy weights focusing
on total body strength training but also
do remember that your muscles are more
prone to injuries so pay more attention
to your warmup and also cooldown what
should you be eating a sturgeon also
helps to suppress your appetite so it is
easier for you to make healthier choices
eat a well-balanced diet you can
increase your protein and carbs
especially after an intense workout
session let's move on to the next phase
the luteal phase this phase starts right
after ovulation which is from day 14 to
day 28 so what's going on I like to call
this space at the roller coaster face
estrogen dips sharply after ovulation
and rises again slightly on day 22
if pregnancy does not happen then both
hormones start to dip so what workout
should you be doing this is the time
where you might be wondering why am I
feeling so crappy why am I losing all
motivation and why can I train as hard
as I used to that's me
high estrogen levels inhibit
carbohydrate access hence you can't hit
the high-intensity like you did the week
before but the good news is your body is
now using fat as fuel not carbs your
body is now burning fat rather than
carbs or glycogen so you really want to
take advantage of this and do cardio go
for steady paced cardio such as trail
runs bike rides or swimming rather than
high-intensity workouts this is also
when muscle breakdown increases so you
will recover slower go for moderate pace
workouts ladies this is when all the
crazy PMS symptoms will start to hit you
might be craving for sugary or high-fat
food you will have big appetite you
might feel bloated your body will retain
more water you might have trouble
sleeping and you might even suffer from
malcolm's you might miss all motivation
but power through your workout eat a
well-balanced diet and trust me you will
feel so much better you might be
wondering why is it important for me to
know this we are all very different and
it takes time for us to understand our
body so with this knowledge you're able
to take advantage of the hormonal
benefits and overcome the challenges by
adapting and adjusting your workout
routine and also food intake I've also
put together a 28-day workout plan to
Train according to your menstrual cycle
so the link is in the description box
below do print it out and start your
training again remember this is just a
guideline as there is very limited
research in regards to training with a
menstrual cycle but do give it a try
make changes and see what works for you
if you find the information in this
video to be helpful do give it a thumbs
up share this video with your
girlfriends and subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more fitness tips you
can also check out my video on period
and exercising and also how to overcome
period cravings right here okay don't
forget to also turn on your notification
button so that you will get notified
every time I share a new video on the
best